the two-way table of column relative
frequencies below shows data on gender
and voting preferences during the 2012
United States presidential election they
give us all of this data they give us
this as they say the to a table of
column relative frequencies so for
example this column right over here is
men the column total is 1 or you could
say a hundred percent and we could see
that 0.42 of the men or 42% of the men
voted for Obama we can see 52% of the
men or 0.5 two of the men voted for
Romney and we can see that the other
that the neither Oh BA or 6% went for
neither Obama or nor Romney and for
women 52% went for Obama 43% went for
Romney 5% went for other and then these
this 52 plus 43 plus 5 will add up to
100% of the women during the 2012 United
States presidential election were male
voters more likely to vote for Romney
than female voters so let's see if we
there's a couple of ways you could think
about it well actually let's go this way
male voters if you are a man 52% of them
voted for Romney while for the women 43%
of them voted for Romney so a man was
more likely there is a if you randomly
picked a man who voted there was a 52%
chance they voted for Romney well if you
randomly picked a woman there was a 43%
a woman who voted there was a 43% chance
that she voted for Romney so yes when
male voters were more likely to vote for
Romney than female voters so the answer
is yes and we're done